voilà ce qu'on a trouvé des bouts de
ferraille il a fallu quand même tirer
dessus pour les déloger de la terre et
puis bon bah sinon un saut alors des
bouteilles en plastique des cannettes
mais aussi des objets plus massif
frigidaire matelas voiture pneus francis
est à l'initiative de cette opération
lancée il ya six ans et il est toujours
aussi consternée de ce qu'on trouve sur
les bords de loire on est déçu de voir
ces déchets qui flotte qui encombrent
les arbres qui encombrent la nature et
puis qui progressivement vont rejoindre
les océans
il se décompose ils se retrouvent dans
le cycle alimentaire ça veut dire que
les poissons les animaux les absorbent
et un jour ou l'autre il y revient dans
notre assiette
une vingtaine de bénévoles ont participé
à l'opération à 8 sur loire et ont
collecté ce matin trois mètres cubes de
détritus
avec une difficulté cependant la loi
donc elle est en crue
donc on peut pas accéder aux îlots comme
on avait prévu de de le faire c'était
pas évident sur les berges qu'enfin la
loire et donc est assez haute et on a
peiné pour récupérer les effets les
chasseurs des douze départements
traversés par la loire se sont fortement
mobilisés aussi pour casser une mauvaise
image qui leur colle souvent à la peau
on est tous des amoureux de la nature
qu'on soit promeneurs chasseurs pêcheurs
randonneurs
voilà c'est notre un peu notre raison de
vivre
donc on aime l'entretenir on la préserve
pour nous émeut futures générations
l'opération était menée sur trois sites
dans le loir et cher
en tout ce sont 26 mètres cubes de
déchets qui ont été ramassés